I found this funny um I didn't know that
y'all were dating and then I found out
that you actually pass notes this is
your thing like which I think is kind of
incredible and so super cute high school
um but you pass notes like during like
on set yeah not just to you like you
just you're you pass notes yeah um yeah
yeah well I was doodling one day in my
little academy notebook you just slide
it in you're just like yeah there go so
Rachel as you can see she I think it's
something cute and
then you're like a something silly she
told me to uh draw her as a flower so
you know I did this really crude drawing
of this flower with a little smiley face
on it and some legs of like just anded
it to her but you know what I'm I'm glad
that that became uh such a story because
afterwards I I got kind of into drawing
I I feel like I got a lot better he's
really harnessed his ability yeah and I
I actually made you something earlier
yes I found out that your favorite
animal is a dog you really like dogs I
love dogs so in the same vein of of this
I decided to draw you as a dog did you
draw me as a dog it's amazing he's so
talented make sure you
show
explain well see see here like you are
such a great team she set that up so
well I was like okay so but there's a
lot of Nuance to this drawing as you see
also cuz you're cuz you're a singer so
that you're barking there's little is in
a musical K you know the really scary
part of this really scary part this is
after he got better this is after he got
[Music]
[Applause]
better thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going home m